cousine de balle mortelle puisqu'elle
est morte c'est qu'elle la place dans le
congèle on n'a qu'à la mecque là dedans
en attendant c'est un valentino mais
faut vraiment qu'elle arrête de faire
des blagues sur sa famille surtout quand
ils sont dissimulés illégalement ans que
j'attendais maison on devrait pas
nourrir les chiens il a pas l'air via la
machinerie tout à l'heure mais la
perturbation est il s'entendait bien
avec charley réussi des longues balades
et tous ensemble
tu penses les animaux sont des êtres
sensibles même la justice l'a reconnu
dernièrement ça m'étonne que tu poses la
question au fait
alors oui mais non en 2015 sous la
pression d'une pétition de 30 millions
d'amis qui avait recueilli 800 mille
signatures quand même
l'animal a été reconnu comme un être
doué de sensibilité révolution juridique
s'exclame l'argent les animaux ne sont
plus considérés comme une table une
chaise maintenant on les respectera
beaucoup plus
sauf que globalement c'est un peu des
bêtises en fait l'article 515 tiré 14 du
code civil nous dit les animaux sont des
êtres vivants d'eau et de sensibilité
sous réserve des lois qui les protège
les animaux sont soumis au régime des
biens
ok donc on a rajouté êtres vivants
nouvelle sensibilité mais à côté on
constate que l'animal est toujours régi
sous le régime des biens ce qui était
déjà le cas avant concrètement rien n'a
changé la question déjà qu'il faut se
poser c'est un être doué de sensibilité
qu'est ce que ça signifie
juridiquement parlant bon à notre époque
actuelle on sait que les animaux sont
effectivement dû être sensibilité ils
ont peur ils peuvent être triste joyeux
il témoigne de l'affection
on n'a plus trop besoin de le prouver
mais est ce que c'est vraiment pertinent
de le rajouter dans le code civil le
sénat avait d'abord refusé cette
modification en avançant que le code
civil se borne à expliquer ce qui est
juste ou injuste autorisé ou interdit
ça peut sembler un peu froid et très
factuelle de prime abord mais le code
civil n'est pas là pour influencer notre
moral même si c'est évidemment notre
morale qui influencent beaucoup notre
droit mais de les inscrire dans le code
civil c'est encore autre chose
ce qui nous intéresse en droit c'est de
donner une classification aux animaux
pour leur appliquer des règles de droit
précise
or dire que l'animal est un être
oui de sensibilité bas ça fait pas
beaucoup avancer les choses surtout
s'ils ont conclu à la fin que l'animal
est toujours soumis au régime des biens
mais j'y viens ça veut dire quoi soumis
au régime des biens endroit un bien
c'est une chose sur laquelle une
personne détient des droits à savoir le
droit d'en être propriétaire le droit de
l'utiliser et le droit d'en récolter les
fruits
donc effectivement vous êtes le
propriétaire de votre chat vous avez le
droit de l'utiliser et s'il a une portée
vous pouvez garder ou donner les chatons
votre animal remplit ces critères dans
votre droit français et ce qui était
déjà le cas du droit romain dont notre
droit s'est beaucoup inspiré on fait une
distinction entre d'un côté les
personnes et de l'autre les biens c'est
ce qu'on appelle la summa divisio la
différence principale entre une personne
et un bien c'est qu'une personne dispose
ce qu'on appelle la personnalité
juridique
ça signifie qu'elle a des droits et des
devoirs elle peut conclure des contrats
etc
les biens comme une chaise par exemple
n'ont pas de personnalité juridique
parce que oui les chaises ne peuvent pas
conclure de contrat jusque là tout
semble logique
donc si on ne veut plus considérer que
les animaux sont des biens on doit les
qualifier de personnes avec tout ce que
ça implique exercice de pensée
si les animaux étaient des personnes en
tout cas assimilés comme des personnes
pourrions-nous en posséder librement
sans leur consentement
il faut pousser le raisonnement jusqu'au
bout pour comprendre le choix du
législateur est pourquoi il soumet
l'animal au droit des biens parce que si
on ne pousse pas le raisonnement
jusqu'au bout pas ça va créer des
incohérences ce qui n'est pas acceptable
en droit ces incohérences elle
risquerait d'entraîner des vides
juridiques
c'est à dire des situations qui ne sont
pas régis par le droit et ça c'est
dangereux car on ne sait pas trop à
quelle sauce on va être mangé et puis
bah c'est peut-on pour le juge qui doit
prendre la décision derrière alors vous
allez me dire mais il n'ya pas que des
personnes et des biens en droit il ya
d'autres catégories
et vous auriez raison en droit on
appelle ça des catégories sui generis
des cas un peu particulier si vous
voulez est l'exemple le plus
emblématique ce serait celui du foetus
parce que oui doit être droit français
le foetus n'est pas une personne au sens
où il n'a pas de personnalité juridique
il y avait eu un cas il ya plusieurs
années d'une femme enceinte de six mois
qui a subi un grave accident de voiture
malheureusement cet accident elle perd
vétus elle a intenté un procès à la
personne qui avait provoqué l'accident
sur le fondement de l'homicide
involontaire et les juges ne retiennent
pas l'homicide involontaire
parce que pour cela il faudrait
considérer que le foetus était une
personne au sens juridique du terme
et j'insiste vraiment que cette au sens
juridique le foetus n'obtiendra cette
personnalité juridique que s'ils né
vivant et viable
le foetus n'est donc pas une personne
mais ce n'est pas un bien non plus vous
en conviendrez il y a pourtant bien des
régimes juridiques qui protège le foetus
par exemple on ne peut pas faire des
expérimentations de clonage dessus et
passé un certain délai on ne peut plus
avorter sans avis médical
c'est donc une catégorie sui generis
loin de la distinction personnes bien et
ça n'empêche pas pour autant une
protection renforcée
revenons à nos moutons pour reprendre
les arguments avancés par certaines
personnes il est complètement faux de
considérer que l'animal est un meuble au
même titre qu'une table en fait cette
tête là que réside tout le problème
on fait une confusion entre le mot
meubles au sens commun du terme et le
mobile dans sa dimension juridique un
meuble au sens commun c'est une chaise
une armoire
nonobstant au sens juridique un meuble
c'est tout simplement quelque chose qui
peut être déplacé le terme juridique de
meubles s'oppose tout simplement à celui
d'immeubles l'immeuble pas comme une
maison ça peut pas être déplacé par
exemple tandis que les meubles pour
cours on peut le faire d'autant plus qu'
accorder le statut de personne ou
assimilés poserait un problème de taille
pour ce qui concerne la responsabilité
et oui parce que qu'est ce qui se passe
si votre chien divaguant dans le
quartier est mort quelqu'un c'est vous
qui en est le propriétaire
donc si la victime vous poursuit en
justice à cause de la mort sur on va
engager votre responsabilité
c'est vous qui allez dédommager
financièrement la victime en droit c'est
donc un régime spécifique en matière de
responsabilité on appelle la
responsabilité du fait des animaux il
est très difficile d'imaginer un autre
régime a
l'icann à ce cas précis quand bien même
les animaux seraient extrêmement protégé
avec un statut très particulier on ne
pourra jamais les considérer comme
responsable au sens juridique du terme
à moins que l'on veuille faire revenir
les pros ces animaux qui ont vraiment
existé parce qu'au 15e siècle on avait
jugé une truie et ses petits porcelets
pour le meurtre d'un enfant
alors bon pour info ça finit mal hein la
truie elle a été condamnée à mort
mais ces porcelets ont été acquittés oui
tenir les animaux pour responsable ce
serait considérer qu'ils ont une vision
du bien et du mal qui change selon les
pays
et puis surtout c'est très ethnocentrée
on ne pourra jamais se passer de ce
régime de responsabilité et je ne vois
pas en quoi il entrerait en conflit avec
des avancées pour les droits des animaux
rassurez-vous ce qui est un peu
enquiquinant avec cette histoire c'est
qu'on a vraiment pensé que la réforme
allait complètement révolutionné le
traitement qu'on fait aux animaux alors
que c'était plus une déclaration
d'intention qu'autre chose et c'était
une façon de faire plaisir aux assauts
de protection animale alors c'est bien
chouette les réformes juridiques mais si
c'est juste pour le symbole bpt.un on
n'est pas bien avancé l'un des sénateurs
s'opposant à la réforme a posé une
question que je trouve pour ma part très
pertinente
une loi a vocation symbolique est elle
vraiment normative regard glitch elle
est juste là elle est juste la journée
en fait si tu veux la voir elle est elle
est là elle est juste en train de dormir
au frais tu veux la voir ça va se calmer
tu veux elle est juste là on parler de
la notion de catégorie sui generis juste
avant et vous allez me dire mais
pourquoi on ne considérait pas l'animal
comme une catégorie sui generis très
bonne question je vous remercie de me la
pose et je vois que vous suivez bien ça
pourrait être une solution un peu
tentante mais en réalité elle ne
changerait pas grand chose à notre
problème puisque je ne pense pas qu'à
l'heure actuelle on puisse entreprendre
une révolution juridique où on
interdirait la vente d'animaux
le fait de pouvoir en détenir ou de les
manger un tel bouleversement ne veut pas
arriver en une seule réforme et savoir
si c'est souhaitable ou non là ça dépend
de vos convictions personnelles et on
sort un peu du droit pur en fait si on
commence à créer des exceptions puisque
la catégorie sui generis est une
exception
on va globalement complexifier tout
notre droit parce que vous pouvez
trouver plein d'autres exemples qui
mériterait peut-être une catégorie
particulière mais il ya un moment où il
faut essayer de classer le plus
sobrement possible sinon on se perd déjà
les sénateurs qui avaient refusé la joue
la mention être doué de sensibilité
avancé que cela avait tendance à
complexifier le statut de l'animal dans
les textes et sur ce point je les
rejoins les règles qui régissent le
droit de l'animal sont complètement
éclatés part tout droit pénal droit des
biens doit de la responsabilité droit de
l'environnement droit rural et c'est
donc pour comprendre quelque chose à la
fin ça devient vraiment pas simple il
existe bien un code de l'animal mais ce
n'est pas une codification officiel si
j'ose dire
c'est l'oeuvre d'universitaires qui ont
tenté de mettre un peu d'ordre dans tout
ça en rassemblant tous les textes
éparpillés mais il n'a pas vraiment la
valeur d'un code civil ou d'un code
pénal
pour le coup il serait peut-être
intéressant de reprendre l'ensemble ces
textes pour leur groupe est
officiellement au même endroit pour des
questions de lisibilité et puis ça
permettrait de montrer aussi que oui les
animaux disposent bien le droit
particulier et ça montrerait pas
vraiment en contradiction avec la
qualification de biens de façon assez
ironique vous en conviendrez
cet ajout d'être doué de sensibilité
était plus globalement contenue dans une
loi de simplification du droit
comme on a tous les ans sauf que les
juristes ne sont pas très friendly avec
ses loi de simplification qui
généralement complique plus qu'autre
chose des notions qui était pourtant
clair et bien établie en créant des
principes d exception des exceptions à
l'exception des exceptions à l'exception
de l'exception de l'exception on a aussi
un peu l'impression que l'animal n'était
pas protégée avant ça alors que c'est
complètement faux vous pouvez balancer
une chaise contre un mur personne ne
viendra vous embêter à part peut-être
vos voisins parce que ça fait du bruit
mais en charge
c'est autre chose en france la première
loi de protection animale elle date de
1850 on a littéralement protéger les
animaux avant de limiter le travail des
enfants
c'est quand même un peu inattendu
intitulé loi grammont elle punit d'une
amende de les mauvais traitements envers
les animaux domestiques
mais en public seulement le député
grammont celui à l'origine de la loi
avait une réelle sensibilité pour la
cause animale en particulier pour les
chevaux à l'origine il souhaitait que
les mauvais traitements dans leur
globalité soient punis pas seulement
ceux en public mais pour que ça soit
acceptée on a dû mettre de l'eau dans
notre vin et restreindre sa aux cadres
publics
ça a changé totalement l'esprit de la
loi les députés voulaient punir les abus
sur les animaux non pas par charité
et parce qu'on considérait que ça
pouvait être une influence néfaste sur
les êtres humains cette conception et
est plus ancrée en son temps une
décision de la cour suprême de l'état du
missouri datant de 1887 expliqué que la
cruauté à l'égard des animaux
manifestent une nature vicieuse et
dégradé et elle tend inévitablement à la
cruauté envers les hommes
on applique la même logique en france
donc punir les actes de mauvais
traitements sur les animaux mais
seulement en public ça pour conséquence
que l'application de la loi reste en
pratique très limité fallait bien un
début le coin ceci dit en cas de
récidive c'est l emprisonnement
automatique
ça montre quand même que cette
infraction et est considéré comme grave
saviez vous que dans les années 1950 on
est passé près loin de l'abolition de la
corrida puisque sa tombe est
complètement dans le champ de la loi
grammont
la cour de cassation avait elle même
reconnu que la corrida constituer un
mauvais traitements et la cour de
cassation quand elle dit un truc
généralement ça va amener des
conséquences assez importante
rétropédalage du législateur et pof en
1951 la loire à manaurie sourbé n'est
permettant de considérer la corrida
comme une exception tolérable est
parfaitement légal en 1959 on abroge la
loi grammont pour élargir le champ
d'application notamment pour que les
mauvais traitements commis dans le privé
puisse aussi être condamné c'est la loi
michel est sûrement l'une des lois les
plus importantes en matière de
protection animale puisque on protège
animal pour lui même et non pas
seulement pour ne pas choquer la
sensibilité du public et en 1963 un
décret va alourdir les peines qui était
déjà prévu
le code rural et de la pêche maritime va
reconnaître par la suite que tout animal
est un être sensible doit être placé par
son propriétaire dans des conditions
compatibles avec les impératifs
biologiques de son espèce
c'est l'article l214 tirer un comme ça
vous savez d'où vient le nom de cette
célèbre association pour illustration en
septembre 2015
on a entendu parler d'un jeune qui avait
tué volontairement lui trois chats de sa
mère il a été condamné à six mois
d'emprisonnement une obligation de soins
et l'interdiction de détenir un animal
autre exemple plus récent en janvier
2020 un homme a été condamné à un an de
prison dont six mois ferme pour avoir
poignardé à mort un chien l'une des
parties civiles stéphane lamart pour la
société nationale de défense des animaux
remarque à ce sujet qu'on commence à
avoir de plus en plus de peines
d'emprisonnement pour les actes de
cruauté envers les animaux
ce qui prouve que les magistrats
prennent conscience de leurs droits et
de l'opinion publique en matière de
cruauté animale les gens sont souvent
très créatif je ne veux pas vous citer
les affaires les plus sordides et
sadique
car si vous êtes ici je suppose que vous
aimez bien les animaux et puis moi ça me
rend aussi un peu triste de lire tout ça
tu vois ce que tu racontes au niveau de
tes trucs là ça me fait beaucoup penser
à la notion d d'image de marque et à
tuer le la perception du public et
finalement c'est ça qui est intéressant
dont tu parle ici parce que dans le cas
des marques
même si là on n'ait pas rempli les deux
marques mais dans le cas des marques ça
arrive souvent qu'elles s'approprient
des causes quand une marque mais elle va
s'approprier une cosse a forcément faire
en sorte que ça a boosté les ventes
auprès de consommateurs qui sont en
accord avec ses valeurs
et là forcément on se demande un peu si
c'est pas un peu hypocrite un petit peu
mercantile comme stratégie c'est pas
très propre finalement comme attention
même si dans les actes apparaît bobin
l'intention derrière et pas forcément
très saine
c'est par exemple ce genre de truc qu'on
va appeler le le greenwashing c'est
l'exemple plus le plus connu est dans
ton cas donc avec cette loi sur la
sensibilité animaux bas même si ce n'est
pas une marque pour moi on a des trucs
très similaires parce que les
associations qui ont un petit peu poussé
le truc pour que cette loi passe
forcément il ya des retombées
médiatiques parce que
c'est comme s'il avait fait une victoire
donc ça leur donne une super belle image
ces gens regardaient sert pas à rien ce
qu'on fait on fait des choses il se
passe des choses n'étaient pas en avant
c'est merveilleux et au niveau de la loi
qui était qu'on connaissait mon ennui un
petit peu genre bah il faudrait faire
des trucs et où ils font une concession
genre bah oui regardez on a fait ça donc
finalement tout le monde paraît gentil
c'est beau tout le monde fait des choses
et au niveau bas de des retombées dans
la presse bat à les défenseurs animaux
qui vont voir des articles passés en
mode cool où on a gagné un truc qu'on a
fait un pas en avant a gagné quelque
chose donc même si en vrai ça paraît
être un parent bien plus grand que cela
puisque derrière serait que c'est du
vide
symboliquement il se passe quand même
quelque chose au niveau de ce que ça
transmet en termes d'image et de valeurs
quoi donc voilà c'est beau pas comme ce
que tu fais ça leur vraiment dégueulasse
toutes ces condamnations ce n'est pas
sur le fondement de l'article 515 tiré
14 ouvre on explique que l'animal est de
8 sensibilité mais bien sûr des
dispositions pénales donc bien plus
vieille qui condamne les mauvais
traitements faits aux animaux le droit
français fait aussi pas mal de progrès
en reconnaissant que le propriétaire
d'un animal peut recevoir des dommages
et intérêts au titre du préjudice moral
ou du préjudice d'affection liés à la
perte d'un animal en cas de divorce très
conflictuelle le juge va devoir décider
qui va garder le chien et va prendre sa
décision avec plusieurs critères comme
la situation financière qui apporte les
soins
est ce qu'il y a un enfant dans
l'équation qui est très attaché à
l'animal c'est bien la preuve qu'on
reconnaît un statut particulier à
l'animal qu'on ne le considère pas comme
un vulgaire tabouret ou un guéridon sans
valeur il y a évidemment plein d'autres
réformes juridiques depuis mai vous
faire une chronologie complète risque
d'être un peu long et chiant on va pas
se mentir et la loi grammont et michel
et c'est clairement celle qu'il faut
retenir donc souvenez-vous que
lorsqu'une réforme juridique est
annoncée
faut se pencher plus concrètement sur
son contenu quand on n'est pas juriste
de formation
c'est assez difficile d'accès mais il
arrive que la presse donne la parole à
des spécialistes de la question ou que
des juristes donne des explications sur
certains réseaux sociaux il n'est
vraiment pas rare de voir des effets
d'annoncé pour instaurer telle ou telle
nouveauté qu'en pratique on a mis en
place depuis plusieurs années mais il ya
un souci à mes yeux est lassé d'un point
de vue éthique
je trouve ça très étrange de dire
l'animal est considéré comme un être
doué d'un sensibilité sans faire de
distinction entre les animaux donc
techniquement selon le droit ils sont
tous doués de sensibilité de la fourmi à
la baleine
et pourtant cette disposition ne rentre
pas du tout en conflit avec le fait
d'envoyer des animaux à l'abattoir
ce que je trouve un poil paradoxal je
vous rassure tout de suite le but ce
n'est pas de culpabiliser les gens qui
consomment de la viande puisque j'en
consomme moi même ce qui me gêne juste
c'est que le droit manque beaucoup de
rigueur et de cohérence dans son
écriture en instaurant une protection à
double vitesse en gros protéger les
animaux de compagnie et puis bah les
autres ce qui me gêne principalement
avec cette nouvelle définition d'être
doué de sensibilité c'est con
sous-entendu coup que certains animaux
sont supérieurs à d'autres
en france il est considéré comme
choquant de manger un chien s est même
interdit alors qu'une vache bas c'est
totalement légal on a légalement pas le
droit d'étouffer une colonie d'abeilles
qui sont précieuses pour notre
biodiversité
mais il n'y a pas de disposition
similaire pour les vers de terre alors
qu'ils sont indispensables pour
préserver nos sols où se fait la
distinction
on protège certains animaux domestiques
commun mais ce que nous avons l'habitude
de consommer comme le bétail ou les
animaux de ferme ne sont pas protégés de
la même façon je ne cherche pas à
culpabiliser qui que ce soit sur ses
choix de consommation mais il a été
prouvé qu'une vache était un être très
sensible ayant des liens très forts avec
son veau par exemple quand on sait ça
est ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu
hypocrite de proclamer ex net redoux et
de sensibilité mais de l'envoyer à
l'abattoir ensuite quand on gave un
canard pour faire du foie gras tout d'un
coup l'animal n'est plus doux et de
sensibilité on protège les animaux mais
seulement quelques-uns c'est
complètement contradictoire est très
fragile sur le plan juridique
si on veut être cohérent il faudrait
aller jusqu'au bout du raisonnement
encore une fois je ne parle même pas des
animaux sauvages puisque cet amendement
ne concerne que les animaux domestiques
en gros l'éléphant n'a pas de
sensibilité visiblement si on résume
et pourtant la science nous a prouvé que
c'était absolument faux tu en vois tu
parles de sensibilité tu parles de quoi
là on sait par la loi le précise pas ok
j'ai par exemple
tu as la douleur c'est hyper intéressant
en biologie ça c'est la sensibilité à la
douleur c'est vraiment subjectif était
la seule à savoir si tu souffres et
combien en fait voilà si tu vas chez le
médecin il va te demandé d'estimer sur
une échelle de 0 à 10 combien tu
souffres ya pas il peut pas gens te
[ __ ] un instrument quelque part et
dire oh tu souffres à 5,3 quoi ça marche
pas comme ça
et du coup avec les animaux comment tu
peux savoir ce que tu peux pas leur
demander et et là tu souffres machin
pour communiquer avec un animal c'est
extrêmement difficile donc là il ya une
solution qui a trouvé là une branche de
la biologie qui s'appelle l'éthologie
qui s'intéresse au comportement animal
eux ce qu'ils font c'est l'idée c'est de
regarder si d'une part il ya les mêmes
structures chez les animaux que chez
nous qui sont responsables de la
sensibilité à la douleur
donc c'est un système nerveux des
récepteurs spécifiques à la douleur ce
genre de truc là et puis d'autre part
ils observent leur comportement voir
s'il ya certains comportements qui
trahissent une douleur donc par exemple
ça peut être un cri d' alerte spécifique
ou alors le fait de se renfermer un peu
sur soi-même éviter le contact avec les
autres
enfin ce genre de truc et ça ça permet
de voir que la plupart des mammifères
sont sensibles à la douleur et même
certains vertébrés pour les poissons on
a des soupçons ne sait pas encore très
bien entendre mais il ya quand même un
défaut à cette approche c'est
l'anthropomorphisme en gros c'est le
fait d'attribuer des comportements
humains à des animaux genre si tu vois
un animal qui boîte tu dis oh là là le
pauvre il a mal à ça se trouve il a pas
mal du tout on sait pas donc ça c'est
vraiment un grand billets dans l'étude
du comportement
et si on pouvait éviter
l'anthropomorphisme ça ferait beaucoup
de bien la science alors on est bien
d'accord
clairement il y à sa tête d'urgence en
matière de protection animale
on protège déjà les animaux des mauvais
traitements on peut les retirer à leurs
propriétaires faire fermer des élevages
abusif
bien sûr il y aurait d'autres choses à
faire par exemple en suisse pour avoir
un chien il faut suivre quelques cours
avec un éducateur avant et il est
interdit de détenir un seul cochon
d'inde
car cet animal grégaire il a besoin d'un
compagnon alors bon les droits des
cochons d'inde ça vous fera sûrement
sourire mais en vrai ces dispositions
sont très justes et pertinentes
on s'intéresse aux besoins des espèces
on met des contraintes qui permettent de
vérifier que les personnes sont bien
responsable et consciente lors de
l'adoption
donc à terme c'est un moyen de lutter
contre la maltraitance et l'abandon des
animaux et ça fait complètement écho à
l'article l 214 tirer un qui dit je le
rappelle tout animal est un être
sensible doit être placé par son
propriétaire dans des conditions
compatibles avec les impératifs
biologiques de son espèce
sauf que pour reprendre le modèle suisse
là on a une vraie application concrète
et adaptée et ça c'est très pertinent
est beaucoup moins vrai qu il y aurait
d'autres combats à mener comme celui sur
l'interdiction des animaux dans les
cirques ou encore interdiction du
broyage des poussins vivant par exemple
ils peuvent parce qu'à l'heure où je
tourne cette vidéo basse est toujours
possible
et quand bien même l'interdiction du
broyage serait effectivement planifié
fin 2021 comme annoncé on va pas se
mentir on a bien pris notre temps
donc bon être vivant de votre
sensibilité est-ce que ce rajout d'être
doué de sensibilité dans le code civil à
changer les mentalités
concrètement non il faut s'interroger
sur nos rapports aux animaux sont nos
modes de consommation de droit peut
initier des changements dans la société
mais il n'est pas suffisant en lui-même
il doit effectivement condamné les abus
sur les animaux mais il ya tout un
travail de sensibilisation à effectuer
dans les juristes ne peuvent pas
endosser la seule responsabilité
je me pose donc la question ne
vaudrait-il pas mieux veiller à faire
respecter les règles juridiques déjà
notre disposition
plutôt que d'opérer des changements peu
significatif c'est ça qui fait bouger
les choses c'est ça qui nous permet
d'ancrer dans les consciences commune
que oui un animal ça se respecte
j'ai pas le temps d'aborder tout le
droit des animaux parce que c'est quand
même quelque chose de plutôt dense donc
si le sujet vous intéresse je vous
conseille vraiment ce bouquin
l'introduction en droits de l'animal que
je vous conseille parce qu'il est plutôt
accessible pour des gens qui n'ont pas
fait de droit donc si le sujet vous
passionne et ben n'hésitez pas merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au
bout j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu on
pourra se retrouver sur discorde pour en
discuter tous ensemble
en attendant n'hésitez pas à aller
et à vous abonner et à partager la vidéo
est sur ce on vous dit à bientôt
or mais charles hey glitch c'était
vraiment une histoire d'amour il fallait
les voir ensemble ces deux là mais c'est
en mai travail est pas oui moi je me
fais pas de souci pour lui je les
croisais de tallard avec un énorme stack
dans la bouche
il n'avait pas l'air malheureux quoi un
stock bah oui c'est des trucs on
décongèle pourquoi on ferait des congés
des stocks alors que ce soir on mange
tous fille je suis actuellement en live
sur twitter pour pouvoir débriefer les
visages sont les animaux avec vous donc
je n'ai pas de chat donc on va faire
tout comme avec son coach aux adorables
donc il ya on se retrouve tout de suite